[Music]
what wouldst thou know my queen magic
mirror on the wall who is the fairest
one of all they may not always talk back
but we've long relied on mirrors to
assess our appearance now one is
providing a lot more than just a
reflection it's putting users into
virtual fitness classes even measuring
their progress with technology that some
says truly does feel like magic when
people see this in person are they like
wow it's not what I expected
yeah the most common phrase we hear when
someone sees it for the first time is
this is the future former ballerina and
Harvard alum Brynn Putnam believes our
fascination with our image is fueling
the next big trend in fitness there's
something really magical about seeing
yourself in the mirror and seeing
yourself working hard she calls her
inventions what else
mirror the mirror is a window to a
fitness experience the world has never
seen before when off that's all it is
but turn it on and your very own
personal trainer it's daring back at you
with instructive workouts live or
on-demand okay I'm looking at him the
good thing is I'm not looking at me
mirrors VP of fitness Kayleigh Kony's I
mean it's at the same rush you get when
you're actually in a gym live it's
almost like even more of a rush because
eventually we're gonna have like
thousands of people that pop up on that
screen just like the idea that we get to
reach so many people with this mirror it
makes it really exciting mirror test
marketed in 100 homes connecting phones
to an app that learned the goals
injuries and preferences of users all
right keep pushing closes range from
cardio and strength to yoga and then
exhale Carlo your hands down to the
floor biologist Joey pecks Nelson is
using mirror to trade for her first
marathon I don't think that without
those cross-training workouts the
Pilates the bar the strength I would be
able to run the distances I just would
have injured myself
[Music]
Putnam herself spent years as a
professional dancer transitioning into
full-time fitness as the owner of a
small studio inside a church the catch
was that every Saturday we had to give
the space back to the church for Sunday
services and then reset the space on
Sunday what did resetting the space
consist of it meant that we had to
actually figure out how to design and
build original fitness equipment that
would be wall-mounted the refine method
studio expanded to 3 New York City
locations but with a newborn patnam
realized she needed to work smarter so I
started to think about how I could take
the studio experience that we had built
that refine and bring it to people in
home largely because it was something
that I needed myself but I didn't want
to put a big piece of cardio equipment a
bike or a treadmill into my home but
connected home fitness equipment is all
the rage with peloton leading the pack
it sold hundreds of thousands of bikes
raising nearly a billion dollars from
investors since 2012 and as high hopes
to continue that streak
with this $4,000 treadmill welcome to
your program other products are also
emerging like the $3,000 digital
strength training system tonal now we've
selected your weight for you
mirror sells for about fifteen hundred
dollars with a thirty nine dollar
monthly membership that provides
unlimited classes all filmed it mirrors
New York City office a lot of consumers
might look at that big-ticket of fifteen
hundred dollars and run away a little
bit right now but that cost will come
down and when it does we expect at home
workouts to be a even bigger trend and
says seen that executive editor Sharon
Profis brick-and-mortar gyms might just
try to get a piece of their action you
can imagine a traditional gym or a
boutique gym also offering at-home
workout options this would actually
bridge the gap between gyms and the home
which is what consumers are looking for
and is exactly why they're reaching for
these products investors have bought
into mirror and have already seated the
start up with thirty eight million
dollars the investors were able to
understand the opportunity for at-home
fitness and then once they saw them your
people quickly fell in love for me it
had to be really plug-and-play in order
to be useful
what Putnam says will help mirror
further stand apart the soon to be
available option to activate a camera
and microphone for a true one-on-one
training how can you make this hack
proof the easiest way we do that is to
provide a physical lens cap with each
mirror so that you can actually
physically cover the device you need to
have your phone with your password in
front of your mirror and then there's a
pin pairing process so that we can
ensure that you're the one using your
device you're ready in these parallels
for an event literally
Tottenham doesn't expect customers to
cancel their gym memberships just up
their game as they zero in on their
reflection is it vanity I think it's
confidence so vanity I think has a
negative connotation but I think we
spend so much time looking in the mirror
and criticizing ourselves or poking at
ourselves this is an opportunity to look
in the mirror and give yourself a
high-five it helps when I see you
working out Chris I tell you that oh
thank you very much Thank You Porter
involvement I like yeah yeah you know I
do it well but I have to say that mirror
really the reflection of yourself
working out is somewhat of a it really
does place you well you pushed you in
the gym when you're lifting weights you
are looking at your form and everything
and I got to tell you if somebody's a
regular gym goer that's really
affordable if you use it and that's
always the key gotta use it yeah